this song you wrote early on at a medium
pace which you know I love because it's
a real romantic song mm-hmm and then
suddenly it's elevated to or degenerated
to just stick that [ __ ] shampoo
bottle up my ass yes it's almost perfect
in the sense that this is how guys are
they start dating they're like they have
romantic love yeah and then quickly it
evaporates into this kind of you know be
really disgusting with me let's listen
to this a little bit yeah this is my
favorite when I was when we did the
record right it was the most excited to
play this I need you some it's pretty
nice ahem yes starting this process
love it's like I'm almost like a country
song look yeah yeah much babies spit on
your hand and Stroke my [ __ ] Adam yeah
and that request comes out of there
that's if she watch me yeah only if you
want so great that's a good one yes what
is mo Ostin say the guy from the record
company when he hears this is he like
wait I got a what the hell are we doing
here I mean you're the guy for Saturn
that live right we're clean yeah I think
they would have been happier with that
but I would when I when I came out and I
was at that age where I was so excited
about getting to release something I
used to call record stores up and say
how's that uh Adam Sandler record moving
there guys and they'd be like is this
sad I'm saying like what no no that's
not me I mean that's not him